all right guys you saw all the
announcements from Cupertino you saw all
the YouTube reviewers talking about the
14 plus the 14 the 14 pro and the pro
Max we've had them in our Studios for
the past few days I've run them through
their Paces let's talk about these three
phones the 14 14 pro Max and 14 pro
which one should you get what are they
about let's get down to it
it's now the 14 plus will not be coming
out till a later date so we'll have the
14 14 pro Max and 14 pro we've got that
deep purple baby that deep purple is
absolutely beautiful this is the color
to have for 2022. no other color is
necessary deep purple or go home let's
get down to talking about the 14 first
because this is going to be the phone I
think a lot of you out there will like
this is essentially the same size as the
14 pro right you don't have that Pro
motion display on this you can have a
really good battery life because of the
display as well they're telling this is
one of the best battery life you've ever
seen out of an iPhone so if you're
looking for something on a budget but
you want that size you want that same
cameras a lot of the same camera
attributes are getting out of the pro
you might want to off for this one this
might be a really good buy for a lot of
you out there I've been playing with
this I absolutely like this a lot for
day-to-day usage I mean if you don't
need three cameras on your phone you're
going to like what this offers to you
you're still going to get cinematic 4K
in this you're going to get really good
optimization on the camera systems out
there the images are sharp there's a
little bit more vibrancy in the 14
lineup when it comes to the cameras
versus 13. something I noticed but in
terms of sharpness in terms of clarity
you're not going to miss a beat you're
going to really enjoy what this phone
has to offer for you and in battery life
as I mentioned is absolutely fantastic
this is your daily driver especially if
you're on a budget let's get down to
talking about the pro phones because
here at geek culture we like to play
with our Pro phones we do gaming xeno's
playing with a lot of games on these
phones what do you think of the gamies
you know
you're right you're right we're going to
talk about in just a bit because that is
something that a lot of reviewers may
not say right off the bat here is that
iOS 16 there has been betas out there
and people haven't had a chance to
develop but with now with Dynamic Island
now with something new attributes to the
14 lineup we're not going to see these
apps mature probably for another month
or so so we'll probably have to visit
you guys again give you more of an
update with the 14 pro and pro Max how
they perform with all those new apps
that are coming out that are going to be
optimized for this processor the a16
bionic chip I love these names bionic
a16 bionic it's so terminator-ish I love
it come with me if you want to live
let's get into the pro first first and
foremost I love this phone now out of
the box it does feel a little bit
heavier by the scales it's not but it
feels a little bit heavier than the 13
Pro you're going to notice one thing the
camera housing is a little bit larger
protrudes out a little bit more and if
you're thinking you're going to use the
same exact cases last year no you're not
Apple has tweaked things slightly as a
matter of fact the power button is just
slightly lower or higher than the 13
just slightly so much so you're going
did Apple do this to us so I have to buy
another case well possibly because also
the camera housing as well and then the
antenna placement but neither here nor
there every year you got to buy a new
Case Case in point I've had my case from
the very beginning and it looks
tarnished it's time for a new case but
I'll go with my 14 pro Max okay getting
back to the 14 pro here for a second
display Pro motion display absolutely
beautiful it's very reminiscent of the
13 Pro guys there's not going to be a
lot of differences here if you're
looking for revolution it's not a
revolutionary year it's an evolutionary
year but nonetheless I like what this
one offers in terms of the performance
it does a very very good job moving on
to this Dynamic island is really cool
now you're not going to see a lot of
what it can do just yet based on the
apps that we have on the phone right now
it you're going to see notifications it
moves around it sort of shape shifts to
what it needs to be I actually like this
the name is a little bit funny but I
like what they're doing with this
technology instead of trying to hide the
front-facing camera embrace it and I
think this is going to be something
you're going to see other phone
manufacturers adopt in time to come you
know what always happens and it will
definitely happen in the future because
this is great and it's great better for
notifications because it doesn't take up
the entire top of your display you just
see there are the eye on the island and
you can just move on with your work okay
in terms of day-to-day performance is
there a difference between the a16
bionic chip and the a15 well on paper
they say there is but day-to-day usage I
would say that the 16 is slightly faster
a little bit more fluid when you're
using it through the UI and you're
opening up some of the Native apps but
it's a minor difference than the 15 as a
matter of fact the 15 is in this in this
phone right here so so the performance
you're seeing out of this phone is very
similar to what you're seeing out of
this phone as a matter of fact look at
it they're almost the same color
ah one difference I noticed I just
realized this this is a little bit more
smoother on the Deep Purple this is a
little bit more rougher here slightly
different texture
a little tip for you right there if
you're wondering what the difference is
between the Coatings there is a slight
difference but outside of that in terms
of performance day to day
very minimal difference a15 a16 they're
so good already Apple's already beat all
the competition it doesn't even make a
difference now they're just having fun
playing around with numbers at this
point in time let's get into what
everybody's talking about though cameras
cameras cameras cameras we've got a 48
megapixel camera system on this now it
is pixel binning and it is going to give
you that same 12 megapixel image out as
a JPEG but of course if you do shoot in
Pro raw you will see that full 48
megapixel image now case in point do not
think this is going to be the same kind
of image quality that you're getting out
of let's say a Nikon z7 II that we're
filming on right now or whatever that
may be sensor size is going to play a
big role and same with lenses these are
small lenses that will also change but
speaking of lenses this is slightly
wider 24 millimeters versus 26 that we
were seeing on the 13 pro and pro Max so
you're getting a little bit wider that
two millimeters does make a difference
but you can just take a step forward and
you'll be pretty much the same but one
thing I did notice is that the colors
are a little bit more vibrant coming out
of the camera system they look a little
a little bit more warmer the skin tone
is a bit more pleasing which I
absolutely love and also the big feature
that is one of the most important
features for me because I'm doing a lot
more video now especially here on this
channel cinematic 4K 24p 30p cinematic
video in 4k absolutely awesome guys if
you've never taken advantage of
cinematic video please do so maybe you
didn't do so because it was only 1080
before and you're shooting everything
else in 4k it didn't work with your
workflow now it does it is beautiful you
can also go back you can edit you can
change the focusing where it's at
honestly I was talking with David Gelb
when he did a short video here in
Singapore about chicken rice a few
months back and he shot primarily with
the Cinematic mode he loved that in
1080. now with 4K
it's a whole new world man this is
exciting with this phone so to me
personally better than even just having
48 megapixels nonetheless the cameras
are really good out of this the
front-facing camera on this they say it
as auto focus now and I'm like but the
other one focused fine I never was out
of focus I don't know I had a yellow box
around me the entire time so I don't
know if there's a different algorithm
that Apple put into it or not I have no
idea but it works great on the 14 pro it
worked great in my 13 Pro Max so
whatever Apple did they did I'm not
gonna argue with them it still looks
good images are sharp it's clear great
colors out of the front-facing camera as
a matter of fact the one thing I like
that Apple does with their camera
systems that you're not seeing from a
lot of smartphone manufacturers is that
the color science from every camera is
the same you don't really notice you're
changing the lens unless you do it
physically if you do that you ask
somebody what lens am I using they
wouldn't know because on some
smartphones out there the main camera is
beautiful it's awesome then you go to
the wide angle it looks like crap or you
go to the telephoto it looks like crap
it's vice versa right but Apple
everything is homogeneous in this sense
where every camera looks the same color
wise a lot of great detail you're going
to really like this the wide angle
camera lens on this is also really good
now the aperture is slightly a little
bit uh slower than last year's but I
mean 1.9 and 2.2 thereabouts if I'm not
mistaken but you're not really going to
notice a difference as a matter of fact
you're going to notice that the image is
slightly sharper now I'm not a big wide
angle shooter but I will use it for
macro macro is one of the things that I
love about using with the iPhone system
and this macro is awesome beautiful you
are going to notice a little bit of a
difference is it going to be night and
day into last year's no but there is a
difference coming into play
okay outside of that though uh battery
life is actually really good I mean I
had no problem with the battery life on
my 13 Pro Max over time it does slow
down but I will say it's been great with
us over the past couple days testing it
it's been fantastic
um and yeah I mean
I got to tell you this deep purple is
beautiful isn't this purple beautiful
Xeno isn't this purple awesome it's it's
so good right it's so good I mean if I
remember correctly this was Steve Jobs
favorite color purple was so they had an
anniversary phone a couple years back
and so maybe that's why they've got
brought it back here for the 14 pro Max
but uh outside of that guys I mean let's
be honest with you for a second we're
not changing the game here with the 14
pro pro Max versus the 13 pro pro Max
right this is an evolutionary change but
the changes that are in place are really
good but we have not seen the potential
yet probably for another month or so
until the apps have matured and
developed to work with iOS 16 and the
new features that are in the iPhone 14
pro and pro Max but outside of that guys
these are our thoughts on these new
phones let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below if you like these
phones which one you're gonna get hit us
up let us know and if you like this
review check out more of our videos
right here
[Music]